the world of
bald men hosting chat shows on streamers
with their name on it is growing by one
how's that for an introduction rex
fantastic rex chapman on cnn plus uh new
episode stream every single monday
always available on demand on cnn plus
great to see you rex chad see you buddy
hey i want to thank you real quick
you just asked me if i'd been here and i
had been here i thought you had changed
the setup but maybe you haven't i came
here you had me here i was living out
here on people's couches
uh for a couple years
and
you asked me to come on and i think we
talked about
we talked about michael playing against
michael and all that but that was one of
my first
even
forays
back into
being seen and heard i was toxic so
thank you buddy rex chapman here on the
rich eisen show you don't have to thank
me for anything yes i do
no
in my mind i do well then that's uh then
i will accept it and you know uh getting
to know you even better you know through
your twitter feed and us direct
messaging with each other
and your remarkable ability to
communicate with people on a human level
to talk to people
and
listen to what people are responding
makes you a perfect
person to host a show
um and i'm not just saying that because
it's called rex chapman you're the only
one who could host a show called rex
chapman thank you i'll accept that i'm
trying to do better with accepting
compliments i'm i come from my dad's
family where i just expect to get cussed
out
and if you're cussing me out then you
don't if you're not cussing me out you
don't really care so did you have to be
armed twisted to do something like this
because you're really putting yourself
out there doing something like this rex
or
what do you know senator got your pod
that's been kind of building your your
skill level yeah
and that that's been
you've been a vital resource for that
because
anybody can be interviewed or at least i
can i've done it since i was 15. um but
doing the interviewing part and having
to listen and having you know a few
bullet points that you want to be sure
to hit
but also being able to follow up
that's been a process the pods have
really
kind of helped develop some of that but
i'm still
i'm still just winging it well i mean
the the interview that we just showed
with uh jason sudeikis terrific and you
um
you went to the set of ted lasso huh we
went to london um
we were in the actual bar they have
actually built a
a set that looks like that bar we didn't
go over the set all the coved stuff and
all that but we we did sit in the bar
and had the that looked like the set
they built a replica on set no kidding
no kidding i don't know if i should have
said that but that's the deal that's all
right that's it's television magic i
love that show yeah it's amazing he's
amazing you know uh
i'm just having fun sitting down with
sports is one thing this is something
completely different and
just to be able to meet some of these
people i've known jason for a while but
being able to meet people like ben
stiller amber ruffin who we
uh are going to have on we've already
taped
kevin love which
we don't talk basketball we talk mental
health the whole time
[Music]
so it's just
it's something different and something i
wanted to try basketball i love
basketball i'd love doing the tournament
and nba tv and
playoffs and all that stuff but
this is just something different i think
i would have kicked myself had i not
tried do you go to each
um interviewee do you go to them and sit
in some spot that's special or specific
to them yes okay and uh it's been just
fantastic i can't believe how
open and willing to talk that people are
um i i've been blown away by and i again
i'm still
you know learning um
this whole thing
from what the producers do to what right
what uh
and the other part of that is
editing man oh my god without editing
we're nothing we're nothing without
quality editing equipment
it's been fast i've always said there's
nothing like being on a team nothing
especially playing on a team
the second best thing to that is being
on some other kind of team right and all
of this like you guys know
it takes all of you guys to pull off
something pretty special every damn day
no doubt and
being a part of a team not wanting to
let down the rest of your squad not
wanting to let down the interview
the guy the person i'm interviewing
right yeah wanting to do right by them i
think is is huge
i've been uh i've really embraced the
studying part because you've gotta you
really need to know your stuff when you
have somebody on that you don't know
well because the last thing you don't
want or the last well that's the last
thing you want
um is
for somebody to make a reference to
something yes that you're like what does
that mean what are they referring to
and they refer to it firsthand because
it's very important to them and you
don't know
i haven't run into that yet but i just
got a hot flash thinking about it
i really did it and and you know um so
you're putting yourself out there and
and i absolutely love that so when you
spoke to ben stiller did you was he
hooked up to the uh meet the parents uh
lie detector i mean
did you do that no we didn't he's not
ready to break out magnum just yet he's
he did divulge
um but no it was amazing um the other
part that was amazing is that
we were able to talk this was you know a
month or so ago six weeks yeah we were
able to talk about severance in the past
tense because i'd seen it and uh what a
great show that was a great show no he
came on it had yet to really begin
airing and um now it's so damn popular
rex chapman cnn plus uh show reg rex
chapman new episode stream every single
monday always available on demand on cnn
plus so uh jumping i guess into the
world of sports as best we can oh
what do you got right there oh you've
got your phoenix so you wanted to talk
sports there you go
i like it
i like it they're so damn good man the
suns are so damn good the best team in
the league i agree they are the best in
three years now here's the thing that
nobody's really talking about very much
and i know that we you you want to talk
about just you know the hardcore hoops
and how well they are playing
i honestly thought when the robert
sarver
report came out that was the end of it i
thought the season's over for them like
how are they going to be able to focus
on the hoops how are they going to be
able to just
lock in and i'm like oh that's right
that's monty williams and then that's
chris paul who's kind of been through
all this sort of insanity before as a
los angeles clipper so they're incred
that's an incredible
backdrop for the lack of a better phrase
to this season that they've been able to
perform
yeah a lot of distraction you know um
one would think i've i've known robert a
long time he's a he's a different guy
but he's
i was really
i was really hurt by a lot of that and i
hope that uh
um they're able to to move past it um
he's been good to me um good to my
family and
you know me and my background and the
things that i stand for and if i thought
for one second that any of that stuff
was
had merit i i couldn't uh be associated
with it i'm i'm a i'm a sons fan i love
the organization and what monty's what
james jones has done
the gm the gm um
the the franchise four years ago
was pretty much rock bottom one of the
worst teams in the league and in four
years they have the culture has really
changed there you talk about it we hear
about that all the time but when you're
around that team for any time at all
it has a real
sort of college
type feel to it
in the locker room monty has pushed the
right buttons of course you've got chris
paul who's
one of the best playmakers of all time
devin booker devin booker is a star he's
a star he's a star no doubt like in my
mind
that's what i wanted my game to look
like
that at six five you know just he can do
everything he's become a determined
defender deandre ayton's growth
uh mikhail bridges
his jump shot
two years ago you
it looked like ray john rondo's a few
years way back in the day yeah he's a
shooter now he can make open shots
sons are for real so the team that
concerns you the most is it in the
western conference
yeah the the warriors you know i still
think that their elite if steph gets
back and and all of that i think they're
they're pretty good i don't think clay
will be quite himself until
fall yeah uh he's still shaking off the
rust but man i'm so happy to have him
back watching him one of my favorite
players um disappointed in the lakers as
most people are um
but yeah and in the east i don't know i
still like miami i think miami's good
the bucks of course
i'm not a big sixer i don't think the
sixers have it why is that um
defensively i think they've taken a hit
um joel's playing great james is
obviously he can beat you anytime i mean
i'm looking at the nets though then
that's just
somehow
how'd you like to play that team in the
first round not at all i wouldn't want
to do that at all and the game plan game
plan for two different guys two top
maybe top five scorers on the planet
how how are you gonna do that especially
and you've had a great season and you're
the two seed and you're gonna play them
i know and and and they're
you know potentially
look
it looks like that they're out of that
worst playing game looks like they're
going to be in the the one where all
they got to do is just beat the cavs and
then they're
they're your seventh seed walking in
look out i know right now and then you
got uh
who is it in the east
that's uh or in the west well oh it's my
sons you want to play memphis
right away no
i hear you i hear you rex chapman here
on the rich eisen show so um
let's just say you sit jordan down on
rex chapman
how's that for an idea
what's that michael jordan let's say you
sit michael jordan down for rex chapman
love it
what do you ask him what do you want
what would you want to know from michael
jordan what would the interview between
rex chapman
and michael jordan be
i think it would be it would start with
you know because i was a like i was a
great player in high school
like all world player that's what i've i
felt like
i saw michael
michael could do that to us sometimes
like
pro players he could
it felt sometimes like you know
he was toying with me
like i toyed with high school kids back
in the day
[Laughter]
and so i would want to know because he
was freaky those big hands and his
demeanor his bounce
his competitive will
i wonder when he
realized that because you know it you
just know it you know if you assert
yourself you can't embarrass
whoever you're playing against
and
michael could get into a mode at times
where
you really were at his mercy and
and
the
mercy of his mood
at the time and if he was if if it was a
playoff situation i faced them once in
the playoffs they swept us like a jv
team in the first round
um
when he's in when he was engaged which
was most of the time he didn't take days
off he didn't rest he played every
single night
um i would wonder when
when he started
you know he got didn't make his high
school team famously when did he realize
was it it carolina was it the shot was
it yeah what was it and when was it that
he realized okay
i'm better than everyone else
that would be a great
question to ask him and then the answer
certainly since you were on the business
end the wrong business and right and and
this is what i try to tell people
who are of a certain age
they never saw jordan play
and i know that it's unfortunate for
lebron that he's on the the end of the
stick
of saying well michael's the greatest of
all time
um
but what you just said i don't i don't
know if we could sit here and say lebron
toys with anybody and would toy with
other professionals i mean he is
stupendous he's going to wind up the
greatest scorer in the history of the
game and a champion and an all-time
great and you know all of those things
and accolades he deserves when it comes
down to it i just remember michael
jordan would
rip your heart out and show it to you
pumping
and then you know put it back in yeah
surgically repair it and then do it
again you know like lebron's a little
more empathetic probably
as an athlete you know we kind of hate
that just as a cut throat you know the
way we're raised right man and you just
go out there and you kill them
uh lebron's not wired exactly like
michael is almost no one is but i
respect the heck out of lebron and i do
think he has had you know he's he's
still amazing he's almost leading the
league in scoring his game is different
than it was seven years ago he was the
fastest man on the planet end-to-end
reckless abandon and he did toy with
people i mean there he's gone through
that i think the older he's gotten he
paces himself a little more and heck
he's played forever
to to put him in the category with
michael is not unreasonable i of course
am biased i think michael's the best
player ever lebron what he's done though
on and off the court he's put himself
out there
you know the guy's never been in trouble
it's never been in trouble he's he's
made you can question
the decision
okay whatever
but that dude from age 17 15 was
supposed to be the
the next guy and he's been that guy i
can't imagine
you know we can't pay enough as nba
people you can't pay guys like lebron
and stefan enough to
you know
put the league on their back like it is
yeah i did sports centers after lebron
high school games
that's how long i i i that's happened
that's right you know i i would i would
do sports centers and lebron's high
school games would be on espn
and you know there were no camera phones
when jordan was doing it there was you
know you know i guess towards the end of
the 80s mike and the mad dog in new york
there weren't shows like this twitter
didn't exist i mean it's a totally
different era in which lebron is doing
it what what year did he come out did
they come out prison uh or lebron and
that class lebron came out 2003. 2003.
that's the year i love sportscenter okay
so i was uh just finishing playing in
2000 and i remember danny ainge
was um
he was
he was doing tv stuff but he was
watching players also and i asked him if
there was anybody out there
this was
2000 2001.
he said there's a kid named lebron james
in akron ohio
that right now i think lebron was a
junior in high school
that right now
i would trade everyone in the league for
with the exception of kobe
what are you talking about and then i
watched some film of him playing
football and then playing also playing
basketball and the only thing he
couldn't do was shoot that was it he
could do everything else his passing was
otherworldly you know defensively he
could he could jump
amazing danny was spot on
there's no question about that and
that's why i'm kind of sheepish to even
bring up the jordan lebron conversation
but again i'm of a certain era right and
you know when you talk about the jordan
mindset you do talk about
uh tiger who's in on the course right
now doing
remarkable just what he's doing amazing
serena you talk about
people of that stature and sort of uh a
mindset and warrior mentality in a way
that does not
get
applied to lebron in the same way and
maybe
because lebron if you remember i mean if
you remember of course you know when you
started it was always he makes the pass
he doesn't take the shot right and he
did that even again just recently that
was uh something that happened yeah that
he got roasted for you know this season
yeah i think some of this too
is the era that we're in you know
when i was playing in the nba
uh especially early on pre-cell phone
and so
you didn't have unless you played
college ball with another guy
you didn't you didn't know them from aau
from the time you were eight
and or ten or twelve yeah all of these
guys you know the trae youngs the little
bronze all these guys
they've known each other on this travel
circuit from the best players in the
world in the country
they've known each other from the time
they're young and i think that there's
some you know remember how weird it was
when all of a sudden larry and magic
were doing a commercial together we were
like what the hell is this this is not
cool they don't like each other and so i
think we've gone through this period
where
you know we remember this analog world
where people didn't you didn't there was
no twitter there was no you couldn't
connect with people you weren't
physically around all the time and so i
think the world is a little different
and these guys just know each other
better and
it's not his cutthroat it's just not
chris you want to ask rex something yeah
rex you did two dunk contests back in
the day 90 and 91. uh just quickly your
experience then what you remember and
then how can they fix the dunk contest
now because it's really bad um
not everybody can say they've been
beaten by dominique wilkins in a dunk
contest he he won it my the first year i
did it they wanted me to do what my
rookie year
begged me to do in the league and i
wanted no part of it i wanted to be an
all-star if i went to the dunk contest
the second year it was in miami the
hornets made me do it i did it it was
fine it was fun
the next year it was in charlotte
um
i got robbed
i still asked d brown how my trophy's
doing making sure it's not dusty
um
no he was great sean kemp was probably
the best dunker that year how they can
fix the dunk contest i've said this
forever the money doesn't really matter
it's not going to be money it's not
going to be whatever find the best
bentley whatever trick it out put it at
mid court
and they're dunking for that
they'll dunk for the car they can all go
buy the car i get it
but it's a free bentley true true and
winner take all
we'll have some dunkers
and there's only one of us one of a kind
one of a kind one of a kind
dunk contest bentley i mean come on rex
why are you fighting
and they stitched the winner's initials
into the
into the upholstery yes
as it's done yes rex why do you think
lebron never entered the dunk contest
i think it was pretty i don't know i
think well for him
it's kind of loose if you lose yeah
exactly yeah
he's the best dunker we know this i mean
at one point he was for sure
i don't know i i think it was just a
lose lose-lose thing plus he probably
already knows the person at bentley to
make him the car anyway for nothing
are you a golfer as well or do you play
golf
strap yep okay i do
i used to be good like when i played
basketball how good were you
at one point i was like a three damn but
i haven't
i
it's it takes everything i have to break
80 at this point all right i'm more by
the way
and i
i also started playing like it got it
was getting to the point that
it felt more like work
like i was trying to get good oh and
forget that yeah i'd miss a putt an
eight-foot putt and lose my mind
like what are you doing this is supposed
to be fun man yeah you need perspective
at that point
uh who was the best uh player in the
association when you were playing in the
association who's the best one danny
ainge is damn good
really good and dan listen to this
yeah danny ain't really good drafted in
three sports scratch golfer yeah he's
terrific and you know big six five
that's not that's not easy that's not
easy yeah but a quick story sure ray
allen's story i was with
danny a couple years ago
at the hall of fame steve nash jason
kidd and ray allen all got in and so i
was there to support steve and jason
danny was there for ray of course and i
didn't see danny until after the
the speeches and whatnot and of course
ray got up and ray is notorious for his
work ethic and he thinks he really does
sort of think if you talk about his
talent that you're diminishing his work
ethic and so ray is all he's military
family and he's routine and and he's a
worker
um and that was pretty much what his
speech was about and i went up to danny
afterwards and said
poor ray allen if he only had some
talent
and and danny said
i played golf with ray last week in
boston i forget the course he said
of course ray's never played on before
and he shot 64.
and i said
what
and he said
yeah
his you know how his jump shot looks i
said yeah i said
like his golf swing looks just textbook
just what
i always usually like ray allen no i
hate it
wow
didn't you imagine 64. you never played
a course you're going out and shoot a
64. and say his
his goals he said he could have been 66.
he probably didn't have a research
i could have exaggerated that a bit and
everything he got game everybody
ladies and gentlemen yeah wow
i love when he's when he's been on ray
allen has been on it's just one of the
many ways to just pick his brain and i'm
glad that he and kg have kind of buried
me too i thought that was beautiful i
saw ray at an mma event a couple years
ago
and uh
walked up to him i said ray man you look
like you can still play he said i can
[Laughter]
back here under a terrestrial radio
outfit rex chapman here uh on the rich
eisen show um so um
i i mean what do you
how how do you decide what you're
posting like today like by the way our
poll question ask him the poll question
based on on his uh oh yeah his tweets i
don't know how big of a baseball uh guy
you are he's the one who tweeted these
specs i understand this i mean i don't
know if he's a hardcore fan like we are
like which baseball movie that came out
today is your favorite sandlot major
league bad news bear you put all three
of those things out but again this is so
easy at this point i have people that
send me this stuff and the guy that
sends me most of the anniversary stuff
great guy just had a baby
congratulations yeah um kevin is his
name yeah but around midnight every
night he just sends me
just sends me stuff and you know it kind
of grows his
his twitter and you've got your own
homegrown curators
you know i used to look for stuff years
ago yes and over time there are two or
three four people really
one in the netherlands
one in london one in chicago and one in
jersey and those guys are magnificent
uh curators and they'll just send me
things and i'll i'll after the show's
over i'll get out of here there'll be a
couple dm's from them and it'll be like
check this out
amazing
so do you have an opinion on because
either i did not know which i could not
believe like those three well baseball
was probably opening day all right yeah
probably so yeah yeah so um no of those
three bad news bears well with you two
but i bet you that's last place because
it's the oldest right yeah it's last
place is it last place it's ten percent
it's gonna be the sandlot it's gonna be
the favorite major league actually just
won off 46 percent sandlot 45
okay but bad news bears tanner does
anybody understand that without the bad
news bears there aren't
fill in the blank of so many movies and
i named my middle daughter tatum is that
right yeah because of no from tatum the
road but think about that jason jason
jason
years before he's not your name
[Music]
named tatum in phoenix but i'll
and tatum o'neill they could say that
i mean walter matthau is butter maker oh
he's a genius you know was he even
nominated i don't know i bet he wasn't i
mean they didn't nominate for movies
like that at that time did they i don't
know
you know he was a genius
everyone needs to go to our youtube uh
page to see this story that i'm about to
paraphrase
for you here rex chapman we had kevin
[ __ ] on who'd be a great guest for
you
uh
and he told a story about walter matthau
that when he passed away on the back end
on the back of the i guess booklet that
they had there for for the
for the day's events and remembrances
were like his his bets from the recent
week before the big time game right yeah
that's right and he and and um they were
on the set of um
oh god
was it the it was grumpy
and he basically was just hating them
being there and kevin asked him
something along the lines of like what
are you doing here he goes the script
stinks kid
but my book he needs my money or
something like that
the script stinks kid
i mean unbelievable
so but i mean it was like buttermaker
come to real life you know and i i
i just love that movie
um so i would guess that too so that's
how you decide what you're you're
tweeting now yeah i mean you're just
probably like when it comes to this sort
of thing pretty much and that's that's
basically how you and i got to get into
significant touch
the blocker charge stuff and i would
just start responding quite a bit and um
and
i'm just look what you've grown it into
man i can't believe it teamwork
makes the dream work it makes the dream
what's your teamwork i mean you're doing
it and it's your fault people are
sending it to me it's
other people's videos you know that's
right
that that people would i find it
fascinating that people think i'm the
feel-good guy and send me you know i'm i
try to be you are
all right
i've
man
i've
i'm all kinds of mentally ill depression
anxiety i get so worked up before these
interviews yeah
like i get nervous not like
not like nervous anxious before a game
like that's but it's
i want to do right by the people i i
want to do right
by you know my sophie who's brought me
to this interview today and i want to do
right by
the people that are investing their time
the cameraman the crew our producers
but mainly the guests i want to do right
by them and and
let them know that hey you know we're
going to have a good time here but i'm
doing my homework well look man i i
understand what you were talking about
uh about whatever fears or whatever you
know um thoughts you're you're dealing
with or whatever my own my own two sense
i would say to you is just be you man
yeah
it's that simple just show up and be you
and if you might not be in the mood or
the right mindset or whatever i don't
know what you whatever you can do to
help you get into that but all you got
to do is just be you yeah people just
want to meet you and talk to you and
pick your brain and hang out with you
and
when you're starting out doing this
stuff did you get nervous and i i you're
pro at this point and you guys just do
it but did you get anxiety
i have anxiety watching um no no i'm
serious i have anxiety watching back
like the first two years of this show
because i'm i'm still
still to this day
uncomfortable having
takes yes like that's not my default is
to tell you what i think right and then
i see some people who were and you're
laughing right over there because he's
because you know these guys teachers
trying to get them to have no because
they're right because
sometimes they're just like you know you
you know get a take and just don't be
you know concerned about it and and i
see the people with whom i compete every
day and i i honestly i sit there and i
think how the hell does their brain work
that way to come up with that
wrinkle on and having an opinion on
something that you really don't even
need to have an opinion on it right
right
so no they've showed me i i saying i i
didn't like watching myself play
basketball good or bad i hated film
hated it
um so this
for sure they had to force me to watch
they had to force me to watch the first
couple
um and
i was pleasantly relieved
that i saw the production of it i saw
the editing they got your back and
yes they got your back but i i was i was
i was just relieved relieved that it
wasn't terrible oh
you know
and and i i can understand yeah you know
you saying that sort of thing but you
know obviously you're with a uh
professional outfit you know jake tapper
wouldn't let that happen to you anyway
and um you know and and you know put it
all together and
you you've got um a persona i like
whoever's chosen the glasses that that's
actually me
okay yeah i've noticed that you got that
you're wearing these glasses i like a
little color
it helps pick me up i think with socks
okay i like it blue socks okay and then
you know and then next time you come on
and then there'll already be a line of
rex chapman glasses you know just bring
us our bring us
bring us some free pair because you know
why we're in this you know rich rex just
brought up socks and there's something
that i've always remembered about rex i
must have been in maybe eighth or ninth
grade there was a brian bosworth was on
the cover of sports illustrated and
there was a story about rex chapman in
there and what i always remember there
were two things about you rex one you
were the first player that ever saw
where the quarter ankle socks that
stopped and you had on a pair of nike i
think revolutions or something i just
always remember that and you were the
first time i ever read somebody say the
phrase my bad
it was a quote that you were playing
basketball i think you threw the ball
away and you were like my bad and that
was something i adopted until yesterday
like i say that all the time so the
quarter sucks it's just funny that you
brought up your socks because you were
the first person in s.i that i saw
because normally we'd have the calf
socks
yeah amazing yeah and
i i could go hug him um well you could
we got a heart out in 50 seconds anyway
so you'll get there
i for real that's true and i got into
into the nba and i'm playing a game in
milwaukee my first game in milwaukee at
halftime ronnie nunn long time ref came
to me and said just got a call from the
league office rex you got to go back in
put on socks that show the logo or you
can't play and so i went in and i
put on and put these logo socks on and
wore the socks but they were always
rolled down i don't know why i did that
but i did and you see people would
notice that i remember did he just get
in the hall running on did i see that i
hope so should have been i think i saw
that i don't know if i saw it my
teammates called me ronnie nunn for a
whole year as a rookie because i was
made to carry the ultrasound bag around
it looked like a doctor's
referee's bag
rex chapman good luck to you sir thanks
for coming on the this place is open to
you anytime soon thank you couldn't be
happier for you cnn plus is rex chapman
every monday new episodes on cnn plus
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here